en quel people va encore perdre de
l'oseille
est-ce que c'est qu'ils jouent la star
de téléréalité benjamin castaldi
laeticia hallyday ou ronald mcdonald
avec la main avec le maintien de la
fermeture des restaurants à ce que
ronald de vie est relatée sous ses
clients mathieu k hallyday laeticia
hallyday et oui laeticia hallyday
mushkin à elle encore une carrière fin
des poissons je l'envoyais des salles
suit des yeux regardez regardez ça fait
un moment que laeticia hallyday n'avait
pas fait reparler d'elle
si durant plus de deux ans de procès
beaucoup pensé qu'elle allait pouvoir
mettre la main sur la totalité de
l'héritage du chanteur ces derniers mois
les choses ont changé et ce sont david
et laura qui ont pris davantage mais
nouveau coup dur pour la veuve du
chanteur c'est aujourd'hui le fisc
français qui lui tombe dessus 13
millions d'euros voilà la somme folle
que laetitia doit aujourd'hui office
c'est le tribunal administratif de paris
qui vient de trancher cette décision en
lien avec des abus de droit a réalisé
par johnny hallyday des années avant sa
disparition une dette colossale qui
s'ajoutent aux 17 millions que la veuve
du chanteur doit déjà réglé au total ce
ne sont donc pas moins de 30 millions
d'euros dont laetitia va devoir
s'acquitter si elle compte aujourd'hui
tout faire pour annuler ses dettes et
remettre en question le jugement du
tribunal la justice ne semble pas prête
à faire machine arrière voilà sept ans
que les preuves s'accumulent pour
accréditer cette fraude
un nouveau coup dur qui pourrait être
fatal à laetitia 30 millions c'est plus
que la part de l'héritage qui devrait
lui revenir si elle n'arrive pas à
négocier ou faire annuler cette dette
elle pourrait donc être ruinés et tout
perdre y compris sa demeure de los
angeles où elle est aujourd'hui confiné
avec ses deux filles
alors bernard montiel est avec nous
juste avant j'aurais un tour de table
alors c'est une histoire de fou match
final la somme de 13 millions d'euros au
fisc
la dette fiscale de johnny remonte à
2010 lorsque les inspecteurs tombe sur
une note accablante rédigé pas rayé par
michel pierre boutin d'avocats
fiscalistes de johnny la tournée en
question c'est tour 66 m'arrêter là 2009
2010 et ça tombe sur laëtitia musculaire
la vérité la bande à boire bien sûr
l'analyse le bernard montiel un
spécialiste de bien sur des
redressements fiscaux et des people mais
combat un petit tour de table va comme à
castanet vous avez des infos non mais
paraît déjà avec vous sur tpp on le sait
depuis le début quand on a annoncé des
sommes mirobolantes pour l'état de
johnny on l'a déjà dit depuis le début
il y avait des dettes fiscales énorme et
je panda pour la vie en acceptant les
[ __ ] il faut que tu aies la dette donc
soit elles paient les impôts seront sato
et ça va être très compliqué parce
qu'effectivement c'est beaucoup moins
que les 100 millions annoncés donc
l'expulsion est très compliqué je pense
d'accord alors 17 ans qu'on peuvent
réagir là-dessus après aura bien sûr
l'analyse de bernard montiel bm choco bn
quand on l'appelle comme la wii specter
de leurs beaux mâles inspecteurs de le
mans il va encore aller mais qu'est ce
qu'il va dire que le couple devait et
que donc que le couple a dépensé en
bagnole ans abba est en vacances en
boîte de nuit et on est plutôt que de le
donner donc finalement ce qu'elle bat de
neotys office
c'est ce dont tu es là profitez en en
disant donc ne s'est pas mis ce qui na
c'est qu'il ya un moment dans la ville
était toujours attraper par la reine
arrive alors aujourd'hui on va quand
même pas on va quand même pas s'en
étonner ou sont offusqués c'est quand
même hallucinant ce qui m'a alors
jean-michel je serai toujours là pour
défendre la veuve et l'orphelin
aucun mandat de l'assemblée tissage
aussi michel david et laura parce que si
on accepte la mairie ta joie simple tout
pour chacun doit payer sa part du départ
du passif donc que l accolade et
j'emmerde tout le monde dort les
zambiens comprend pas que beau dans un
héritage ont tout pour qu'ils partagent
à des tons 3 aux usa on à rené
malleville qui a été guitariste de
johnny de deux saucisses
oui oui non mais tu sais moi j'ai jamais
pupitre et septembre
en plus c'est son père qui a pris la
direction des affaires de johnny
hallyday à billets et david hallyday et
laura si vivante à cet égard sont légion
et robbie moi j'ai rien contre elle
franchement j'ai rien contre elle la
pauvre elle va prendre 13 millions dans
la gueule mais je connais un rayon mais
après on aura même à mon nom mais après
jean-michel il a soulevé un point qui
est intéressant et mathieu dévorer
pendant dix ans elle a dépensé avec
johnny mais maintenant les millions
qu'elle doit au fisc n'ont pas inventé
13 millions comme ça le fisc si l'on dit
13 millions c'est qu'ils ont tous et cet
argent
mais là où j'en viens à raison c'est que
la laura et david il va falloir qu'ils
viennent aussi pour les 13 millions si
vous voulez le reste du gâteau faut déjà
réglé ce problème des 13 millions et
jean-louis la raison c'est vrai que si
mal il m'a scotché jambes il alors oui
benjamin mais juste ballon mais pour
l'instant les villes de saint marc c'est
elle qui est dedans
la maison c'est rien dedans pour
l'instant laura et david excusez-moi si
l'on use héros donc c'est plutôt à elle
qu'il faudrait cheptel de rendre plus
tôt avant partager d'accord mais ils ont
manqué de rien voir tous partagent les
emmerdes du parquet de huy le cab est
encore chère encore que d'écouter le
fruité verona bernard montiel spéciale
il peut dire l'héritage contrôle fiscal
bien sûr et on l'a donc oui et oui alors
oui oui mathieu dolan oui je peux dire
un mot avant parce que pardon mais on
tombe effectivement sur laëtitia mais
personne n'ose pas dire ce que je dis
mais tant pis je suis en forme
enfin pardon aussi en train de découvrir
quand même que johnny père au namm bien
sûr ne peux pas répondre
pardon enfin toute la fraude fiscale
c'est pas laeticia hallyday qui gérait
l'argent et c'est pas elle qui touché
d'argent dont parlent
et entendent aussi du beau jeu des fans
mais johnny c'est peut-être qu'il avait
des mauvais conseillers et les affaires
non mais je crois pas que johnny les
pistes il savait et john il s'agirait
rien du tout il avait des conseillers
fiscaux il faut vous dire le pauvre de
chennai pour aller bernard montiel
répondu à toutes les questions que la
mère d'alexis vous plaît on se calme
tant que sage d'abord ne soir c'est pas
le père de laura qui s'est occupé de ça
ce moment là c'était sa date de 2009 de
laetitia 15 social le perdre et issia
c'est vrai que le début des problèmes de
laëtitia parce que le fisc et sur elle
depuis un bon petit moment là ce sont
les fiscalistes de johnny qui ont essayé
de faire un montage pour éviter qui peut
à sa prestation du chanteur avec les
sociétés écrans comme nabajoth issa et
saer lé pilote ça s'appelle nerthe us
voilà naïve est donc en fait laetitia y
est pour rien sans les fiscalistes de
johnny qui ont mal géré la faire mais
ses 13 millions ça y est elle est doit
doit les payer à la paire du procès ça
c'est clair
mais croyez moi qui aura deux procès
derrière parce qu'il aura d'autres
problèmes encore quant aux vies laquelle
à saint barth elle en a trois maintenant
on le sait pas tout ça a été dissimulée
aussi croyez moi que le fils qui vont
s'occuper
d'accord vous savez comment il a réagi
laetitia on sait pas si je les soutiens
comment il a réagi
j'ai une personne qui a une copine elle
très proche qui effectivement m'a dit
que c'est un drame évidemment quand même
millions elle espérait en échappée parce
que dans le trust américain qu'elle
avait constitué qu est une sorte de
bouclier fiscal il est bien précisé
qu'elle devait toujours maintenir son
train de vie et ce à son train de vie ne
peut plus le maintenir mais je rappelle
quand même qu'à un capital de 100
millions
la touche et 50 millions pour moment
puisque les autres 50 millions son jeu
les accords pas de déguisement constitue
qu'un pleurer sur elle un holà